[Música]
las fronteras son peligrosos en todas
partes
tengo que ser cuidadosa mantener la
guardia alta viviendo aquí pero a decir
verdad todo parece bastante tranquilo
hoy
[Música]
pero ya además del muro tiene otra otra
regla 9 que dice los migrantes tienen
que quedar en méxico
[Música]
los inmigrantes son la parte más
importante de nuestra comunidad
honestamente
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
postales de campaña la cobertura
especial de france 24 en estas
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu
hoy nos detenemos en arizona uno de los
seis estados que podrían decidir al
próximo presidente de este país esta
zona es famosa por sus paisajes
desérticos y sus campos de cactus pero
también por ser un histórico bastión
republicano en el que los demócratas
poco a poco han ido ganando terreno
sobre todo gracias al apoyo de las
mujeres blancas en los suburbios y a una
población joven latina en edad de votar
que se ha movilizado en los últimos
meses recorrer este estado fronterizo
nos permitirá entender mejor cuál es el
papel que juega la inmigración en estas
elecciones presidenciales que sabemos de
arizona ubicado en el suroeste de eeuu
el estado de arizona es vecino del
estado de california y especialmente de
méxico al sur
[Música]
apodado el estado del grand canyon es el
sexto más grande de eeuu con más de
siete millones de habitantes ofrece 11
votos del colegio electoral un estado
clave en la conquista de la casa blanca
la mayoría de la población tres quintas
partes se concentra en una sola región
la capital del estado phoenix arizona es
un estado rojo rojo como el cobre que
produce en cantidad y rojo como el
partido republicano que ha elegido
muchas veces entonces porque arizona es
un estado pendular tradicionalmente no
lo es desde 1952 el estado ha votado por
el candidato republicano excepto en 1996
cuando colocó a bill clinton a la cabeza
pero en 2020 arizona está al alcance de
los demócratas y la razón principal es
demográfica la población de arizona se
ha multiplicado por 7 desde la segunda
guerra mundial los recién llegados
principalmente emigrantes en su mayoría
mexicanos desde entonces muchos han
obtenido la ciudadanía estadounidense y
pesan un tercio de la población votantes
latinos que en su mayoría votan por
así que por lo tanto podrían cambiar a
arizona
[Música]
la cuestión migratoria ha quedado
completamente desplazada por la pandemia
en estas elecciones presidenciales sin
embargo continuó ocupando un lugar muy
importante en la vida cotidiana de las
ciudades como estatus son cercanas a la
frontera entre méxico y eeuu
yo lo creo en un muro no creo en las
fronteras no creo que se deba encerrar a
los niños separados de sus padres pienso
que debería haber muchos cambios en la
política de migración pero ya sabes si
se está construyendo un muro contra los
abusadores sexuales contra los
traficantes de drogas entonces creo que
es una buena idea tener algún tipo de
protección pero los inmigrantes ilegales
no deberían ser un problema de
inmigración nunca es algo malo porque
estamos todos aquí todos somos
inmigrantes de acuerdo he hablado con
gente que vive cerca del muro y están
muy contentos con él
al parecer ha detenido muchos cruces
ilegales y muchos robos de ganado
entonces se puede entender los dos lados
de este asunto
en la última década arizona se ha
convertido en destino de residentes de
otros estados más liberales como por
ejemplo california esto ha supuesto un
cambio en el mapa electoral y mientras
que en la capital phoenix y sus
suburbios apuestan por el bando
republicano en zonas fronterizas como
esta votan demócrata aquí viven la
mayoría de los latinos y no le perdonan
al presidente estadounidense sus
insultos ni comparten esa visión que
tiene donald trump de cómo gestionar la
frontera así se lo han contado a un
equipo de france 24 la mayoría de las
veces me lisa owen lleva una vida
tranquila su rancho está cerca de la
frontera y lejos de todo lo demás
aislamiento incendios inundaciones
conoce los riesgos las fronteras son
peligrosas en todas partes
tengo que ser cuidadosa mantener la
guardia alta viviendo aquí pero a decir
verdad todo parece bastante tranquilo
hoy el british foods m
cientos de emigrantes pasaron por su
propiedad melissa está armada por su
protección pero un muro en el desierto
nunca detendrá la desesperación de un
continente nuevo si nadie quiere una
frontera más segura que yo porque es
donde vivo pero el muro no es la
respuesta necesitamos construir puentes
y trabajar con todos estos países en
working y poder
[Música]
una hora y media más al este la frontera
es percibida de otra manera las personas
estamos en nogales es la ciudad más
singular en los 2500 kilómetros de
frontera para mí porque en realidad es
una ciudad partida en dos por el muro
después ya número vuestra voz
alex lapierre trabaja con la border que
minería lines una ong aquí los
intercambios con el vecino méxico
siempre existieron así que alex está
luchando contra los clichés sobre la
frontera y parece que en eeuu cuanto más
lejos de la frontera más prejuicios se
tiene al equipo mucha gente piensa que
en esta zona es una zona de guerra con
minas terrestres por todas partes y
gente con ametralladoras y en el lado
estadounidense las tiendas como la de
vancouver y se quedan vacías wind that
happens el cierre de la frontera no deja
que el 95% de nuestros clientes entren
from coming up antes de la pandemia ya
había menos visitas desde bill clinton
cada administración reforzó gradualmente
la separación a pesar de sus promesas
donald trump sólo añadió unos 50
kilómetros de muro principalmente renovó
una valla que ya estaba en el lugar por
ejemplo se instaló este alambre de púas
en el otoño de 2018 la mayoría de los
20.000 habitantes de nogales no lo
quieren ya lowers así el alambre de púas
ya sabes nos esforzamos en ignorarlos
porque es demasiado deprimente pensar en
todas las cosas que simbolizan todos los
que crecieron aquí tienen familia a
ambos lados de la frontera así que
permanecer en un lado no es nada natural
para nosotros o fraser
el año pasado se abrió una galería de
arte a pocos metros del muro es una
forma de resistir para contar otra
historia de la frontera
[Aplausos]
en los últimos 20 años cerca de 8 mil
migrantes han perdido la vida tratando
de cruzar la frontera entre méxico y
estados unidos atravesando desiertos
como este pero otros muchos han
sobrevivido gracias a la labor de
personas como bot faymann
el vicepresidente de la organización
fronteras compasivas que distribuye agua
en el desierto para que los inmigrantes
que quieren llegar a eeuu no mueran
deshidratados voz que le mueve a hacer
una labor tan dura física y anímicamente
es la combinación del arte y la historia
de mi país y la historia de mi familia
nosotros somos judíos mi ser wells y
aunque fuga de europa porque con los
judíos solamente por ser judíos nos
estaban matando es una historia que
conozco bien y también me acuerdo un
poco de la escuela religiosa donde me
mandaron mis padres la historia de
moisés en el desierto yo estuvimos por
40 años atrás de él perdidos si después
de la historia demuestra perdidos en el
desierto por 40 años si hoy en día
encontramos otras personas ahora mismo
camino y nosotros los judíos nos traemos
ganas de ayudar no estamos
[Aplausos]
nos encontramos en sal sabe un
pueblecito que está muy cerca de la
mayor promesa electoral de donald trump
en el 2016 que es precisamente este muro
que separa a méxico de eeuu
cómo ha cambiado aquí la situación desde
que trump llegó al poder pues primero
tenemos más muro como usted puede ver el
muro está más largo ahí en la distancia
se puede ver dónde se pare y dónde sigue
la construcción igual que los vehículos
que están haciendo el trabajo y también
amor está más alto pero ya además del
muro tiene otra otra regla 9 que dice
los migrantes tienen que quedar en
méxico que dice que el aflujo el flujo
de gente que vengan del sur al norte me
creo que está más o menos igual
dependiendo en la temporada pero la
cantidad que pueden cruzar ha bajado si
crecen no llegan más lejos de la
frontera que los edificios allá de la
migra y la migra en lugar de tomar datos
y mandar el del señor la señora el
cáncer dicen ahora que tenemos sus datos
tiene que caminar y volver a quedar
tiene otro lado de la mente de nadador
mexicano
ha bajado en esta zona pero en otras se
ha disparado la entrada de inmigrantes
desde méxico a eeuu qué ventajas o
desventajas tiene cruzar la frontera en
esta zona de arizona
pues la palabra ventaja en otro seguro
que es la palabra correcta en los ojos
de ellos posiblemente si el flujo
depende en donde hay vigilancia y donde
hay capacidad
ellos tienen capacidad de conseguir
información de lo que hacemos nosotros
haciendo este lado si sepan que aquí
tenemos mucha vigilancia van a buscar
otro lugar en que crecer y si aquí no
hay muchos van a escoger esa se ve como
el punto es un flujo que depende de lo
que se ve por las noticias y también
claro que la temporada y cuál es el
perfil de migrante que atraviesa esta
frontera pues en los tiempos aquellos
digamos durante de mi juventud porque
tengo más años clic acá
allá tuvimos un flujo casi puro mexicano
ahora tenemos un flujo de toda
latinoamérica del centro de mercado así
como un par de semanas tuvieron y tuve
la oportunidad de comunicar con este
cubano ayer estuve en el otro lado
comunicando con algunos guatemaltecos
el jueves en locales con más cubanos son
jóvenes o son hombres son mujeres es la
combinación de hombres de mujeres de
familias los niños siempre viene
acompañado con adultos yo en todo el
tiempo que tengo que ir trabajando donde
tuve la oportunidad encuentra de un niño
solo tram ha sido muy criticado por esa
política de separación de familias
todavía hay 544 niños cuyos padres no
han sido localizados creo que esta
política disuasoria para que entren
familias en estados unidos sin
documentación ha sido efectiva ustedes
han visto un cambio pues eso me pregunto
yo no creo que tenga la respuesta final
hay que entender que la gente que está
en jugando que están viajando el norte
vienen de una pobreza que nosotros nos
conocemos que queremos conocer vienen de
un lugar donde sus tiendas pueden ya
quemar
sus cuerpos puede estar violados cuando
viene de un lugar tan peligroso no anda
pensando qué va a pasar cuando llega a
la frontera y además de eso creo que los
que están ayudando a la gente viajar son
personas que me quieren ya compartir la
verdad con sus pasajeros solamente
quieren cobrar sus tarifas y decidieran
ya nos vamos a darnos muchas gracias por
acompañarnos hoy me gustas y por venir
la población latina representa un 13%
del electorado en estos comicios un voto
muy deseado por ambos candidatos bailén
promete deshacer todo lo que ha creado
donald trabe en política de inmigración
por su parte el presidente
estadounidense no planea renunciar a su
plan de tolerancia cero' en la frontera
hasta aquí nuestro programa de hoy
nosotros ponemos ya rumbo a wisconsin
para abordar la que posiblemente sea la
mejor carta electoral de donald trump en
estas elecciones la economía acompáñenos
en este viaje electoral a través de
nuestras redes sociales o en la página
web trans 24 punto com
y